hola buenas tardes
buenas tardes a todos los que se están
conectando
bienvenidos a este webinar con khan
academy mi nombre es laura camacho y el
día de hoy la sesión está muy
interesante porque tenemos una invitada
especial tenemos a una maestra que nos
va a estar compartiendo su experiencia y
sus casos de éxito sus retos trabajando
con khan academy y
y en el trabajo día a día con sus grupos
su nombre es luz emilia y ella está en
chihuahua
ella está en conalep en el campus 2 en
chihuahua chihuahua y en y es parte
también del servef y 122 entonces su
experiencia es muy amplia es uno de
nuestros casos de éxito más
identificados y queremos seguir teniendo
más casos de éxito y de buenas prácticas
como el de ella entonces creemos que es
una excelente oportunidad para que todos
la conozcan y puedan tomar de su
experiencia
lo mejor para llevarlo a ustedes también
a sus aulas
entonces como éstas los emilia
bienvenida
muy buenas tardes maestra laura un
placer estar aquí
muchas gracias por la invitación hombre
muchas gracias a ti cuéntanos 12 miles
me contabas o nos contaba que estás
tanto en con la leb como en cebetis es
cierto así es es cierto bajo qué
materias gas actualmente estamos en
matemáticas 3 geometría analítica quién
conalep tos y en el cebetis estamos en
álgebra entonces aquí tengo dos clases
abiertas y tres en el cebetis guaus las
cinco clases y cuánto tiempo tienes
usando cada acá db
yo sabía de los vídeos de la plataforma
no de la plataforma en sí de los vídeos
cuando exploraba también química ellos
y ya de lleno este estuvimos en la blair
store tengo mi constancia de docente y
mis grupos también todos logramos el
reto
en el otro plantel es
y ya se dio continuidad y me interesó
mucho esta de del campeonato
ok pero vaya tienes ya varios siglos
escolares trabajando con carla academy o
apenas ahorita no si ya tenemos algunos
dos años usando dos años ok como ha sido
para ti independientemente del
campeonato ahorita tocamos esa esa parte
pero como ha sido para ti
trabajar con khan academy en estos dos
ciclos escolares has visto algún cambio
en la mejora de tus alumnos en cómo
están aprendiendo o no cuéntanos un
poquito
es de doble doble importancia porque
este tanto estamos abordando pues los
contenidos temáticos de los aprendizajes
que abre aprendizajes esperados de la
currícula pero también pues la
plataforma es muy amplia esté de acuerdo
las asignaciones del tema que se esté
viendo por semana se asignan en
actividades de reforzamiento y ellos
retroalimentan de que vieron otras a
otros materiales otros recursos entonces
no norma se están limitando a las
asignaciones entonces para mí ni si ha
sido de crecimiento también profesional
en el cual algunos también tienen
algunos problemas de acceso y para mí
también es este es el ir al día con
ellos estar aprendiendo
tengo un habla sin nada con cañón
entonces ahí vemos sus desempeños y
algunas dudas que ellos también den
algunos surgen y unos como son nativos
digitales que ya sabemos que van esté
aún más allá y también disfrutan las
matemáticas cómo hablar ahorita mi
instructor pues hay que hay que
disfrutar no no de que sea algo
trabajoso sino de placer de
entretenimiento y alameda a la vez pues
estamos creciendo académicamente
profesionalmente ok
excelente hay algo del contenido que tú
hayas estado utilizando en khan academy
que hayas visto que ha reforzado lo
mejor huecos conceptuales o que traían
ya tus alumnos desde atrás por ejemplo
que te identifiques que ahí hay
partes no sé de álgebra o de operaciones
básicas
no fueron bien trabajados o bien
aprendidos anteriormente y que se hayan
reforzado con kant y eso a la vez te
ayuda a ti en tu día a día en tus
materias
exactamente es este grandioso los
contenidos de la plataforma en sí de las
matemáticas que vienen desde el nivel de
primaria secundaria y si cuando nosotros
en este nivel encontramos mucho rezago
educativo en cuanto a las operaciones
fundamentales entonces para entender el
álgebra pues traen mucho hueco mucho
rezago en cuanto a la aritmética
entonces es grandiosa la plataforma
porque ahorita genera algunos grupos de
esas cine 30 actividad de fracciones a
otros 50 otros 90 de acuerdo a la
necesidad de cada grupo y unos no la
requieren pero si lo estoy agregando en
general al grupo para que igual no haya
esta discriminación o distinción de que
porque a mí me está cargando más porque
hay a las personas no yo lo estoy
haciendo grupo aunque sí tengan el
dominio poquitos pero eso fue grandioso
para mí de que me está ayudando
muchísimo y no tengo que estar repasando
el algoritmo de la fracción tiene el
álgebra pues
no no lo dominan en cuanto a las
fracciones entonces khan academy te
ofrece eso que te presentan los vídeos
de 2 minutos de manera sencilla te
explica las fracciones y luego te da las
actividades a realizar
entonces ya los siguientes temas de
radicalización que es un tema jan y saca
raíces de quintana de la quinta la sexta
es ya muy fácil este con mis alumnos
los veo que no se les complicó el porque
ya han realizado diversas actividades de
la plataforma que les ofrece y por las
horas de clase en vivo presenciales son
cinco entonces son insuficientes para
abarcar a cada la diversidad de
estudiantes que tenemos entonces esto te
ofrece carga de mí que ellos en su
momento se estén
en cualquier momento pueden accesar y
avanzar y mejorar académicamente
excelente como has logrado que tus
alumnos se mantengan interesados en khan
academy o sea que hacer tú como maestra
porque trabajar con realmente con
jóvenes de prepa no es fácil lo que les
interesa ahorita quizá mañana ya no
entonces como has logrado que ellos se
mantengan interesados tienes no sea
algún esquema en donde les cuentes para
su calificación si ellos contestan a
actividades o si entran a la plataforma
o algo así o no si desde el inicio en el
encuadre mis criterios de evaluación de
ponderación se establece un punto dentro
de los del 10 un punto por realizar
actividades este en la plataforma
entonces si ya saben que es un punto y
en la primera parcial no fui tan
en ver qué tantas actas realizaron nada
más es que yo veía que si estaban
activos y les
es proporcione su punto uno es que no lo
habían intentado pues ya en este segundo
parcial tengo grupos de 56 49 y 47
estudiantes
y es grandioso también para mí fue
importante que al proyectar las
actividades el avance que reflejan había
personas que yo no detectaba por lo
calladas que son el momento de proyectar
el listado y quién es este christina
olivares si ya levantaba su manita la
persona muy tímida y vea que ella tenía
un desempeño este completo correcto de
actividades apenas las asignó y al otro
día ya muchos ya las realizaron entonces
de si detectas hay personas que en el en
la prensa en presencia pues no lo logras
identificar quién si está
desarrollándose no por la nueva por el
tiempo por lo numeroso del grupo
entonces también hay academy te permite
eso que yo esté monitoreando desde mi
espacio en cualquier momento como vanish
grupos quien está resolviendo y quién y
si es sorpresa agradable de personas
calladas que no son participativas
esa rom en la pre en vivo y ves que es
de gran participación tienen en la
plataforma entonces sí ha sido también
muy satisfactorio pero fíjate que esto
es interesante porque generalmente
pensamos que si no estás participando en
la clase o levantas la mano es que no
entendiste o no te interesa pero pues
también tiene mucho que ver la
personalidad del alumno a lo mejor no
simplemente no quiere participar pero si
está trabajando en la plataforma y si tú
estás viendo que está teniendo un buen
desempeño
si se reflejan las calificaciones pues
eso habla también de nuestro buen
trabajo como maestros así es si es que
son personas muy tímidas
pueden ser antisociales no socializan
mucho aisladas pero en la plataforma es
donde ellos impactan este donde yo veo
su desarrollo y ha sido sorpresas muy
favorables oye los familia
porque te animaste a participar en el
campeonato
a mí me gustan los retos y aunque
batalló y ahorita me agradezca un
instructor este
que me aclaró unas dudas yo batalló con
la tecnología pero siempre te pegaba mi
computadora ja me levanto con ella y me
duermo con ella entonces qué es lo que a
mí me agrada y cómo interactuar es que
utiliza otra plataforma educativa de
modo pero yo preparar mis materiales me
pueden ser unos vídeos pequeños pero
aquí pues ya está todo estructurado todo
está listo nada más para listo para
usarse entonces éste en cuanto a supe
también del campeonato pues sí me
interesó muchísimo y pues no es una
competencia no es un torneo nacional es
de avance en cada grupo y de cada
persona de cada alumno entonces para mí
pues
me encantó la idea y pues aquí estoy
mira fíjate que esa parte también es
importante porque muchos de los
profesores que se han acercado con
nosotros a lo largo de estas seis
semanas del campeonato piensan que es un
reto pero de mi colegio o de mi campus
versus alguien más y no es así o sea si
es un reto pero dentro de tu propio
salón con tus alumnos o sea
el chiste es mejorar el desempeño dentro
del dentro de la escuela pues dentro de
tu propio grupo y me parece muy
importante que tú hagas esa aclaración
así es
hay algunos alumnos que me dicen es que
no llega a la red de donde en mi
localidad donde yo vivo o no tengo la
computadora se descompuso el internet y
así como les digo siempre hay un
amiguito que te la pueda prestar y te
puedes entrar con tu con tu cuenta y
este un dispositivo un celular y también
en las bibliotecas en nuestros planteles
tienen internet pueden en un receso en
una hora libre entonces no es motivo
también de que ya no participemos y no
pues ha habido un gran aceptación y la
verdad sí sí sí está si vamos avanzando
claro que hay mucho por trabajar todavía
este pero sí siento que vamos este
avanzando
y los de vélez cuáles han sido tus
principales retos al trabajar con can y
en el campeonato
pues el que implante el 2 lo que yo
estoy solicitando es una hora de para lo
mismo para aclararles para acompañarnos
desde el acceso de la cuenta
tengo se les ha complicado más entonces
yo llevarlos más de la mano de la mano
para esto
para que se familiaricen pues con la
plataforma y vean que es muy amigable
ese ha sido el reto en cuanto a un grupo
en especial aquí que no logrado la el
total de qué
son muy pocos y allá este me faltarían
cinco personas en su mayoría ya todos
están participando este fue el primer
reto de que no crean que les voy a
saturar eso si cuido mucho
en el tema que esté viendo el tema
evaluar pues asignar las los vídeos y
las actividades que sean suficiente no
saturarlo tanto porque pues si la
plataforma tiene muchísimo material
muchísimo recurso entonces de que
también tengan su vida de jóvenes
también disfruten su vida de actividades
propias de la que tenga tiempo para
crecer en lo académico claro además
recordemos que para participar en el
campeonato necesitamos como un como
mínimo asignar tres actividades a la
semana entonces no se trata de saturar
los a ellos ni saturar nos nosotros
teniendo que estar revisando el avance
con tres que dejemos a la semana está
perfecto
así luz emilia estás tú también dentro
del campeonato integrando las
actividades de mentalidad de crecimiento
o solamente te concentras en tu materia
no también las de crecimiento se me han
hecho
e incluso los adultos este sí muy
importante son relevantes entonces si
éste si las estoy integrando las de
crecimiento perfecto estas en
actividades de mentalidad de crecimiento
recordemos que son para digamos
desarrollo de habilidades del
pensamiento emociones y ver el fracaso
como una oportunidad de mejora
entonces para todos aquellos que sí
están participando en el campeonato y
estén
trabajando con khan academy le sugerimos
que agreguen si no lo han hecho que
agreguen el contenido de mentalidad de
crecimiento en sus clases para que
puedan reforzar el avance de los alumnos
también desde otra perspectiva no nada
más desde la materia además de que las
actividades de mentalidad de crecimiento
dan más puntos
entonces tómenlo muy en cuenta también
por favor
en
qué le dirías
a tus compañeros que todavía no están
usando khan academy o que ya están
usando card academy pero no han entrado
en el campeonato cosas son digamos
nuevos como como podrías tú alentarlos a
que usen la plataforma luz emilia
qué más de que piensen en un paradigma
de que va a ser más trabajo de revisar
porque a veces eso pensamos este como
pues hay un maestro presencial no en
línea como voy a estar trabajando en
línea no de que vean que al contrario va
a ser muy favorecedor no vamos a estar
batallando tanto para explicar este
porque pueden dar la clase inversa
primero en decir que revisen los vídeos
los materiales y luego ya explicaré en
la manera tradicional en el pizarrón
entonces que se animen que está muy
amigable no está esté complicada está
ágil yo comparto mis datos yo tengo
plantel se la llevará a un comercial en
el que la sede
y es increíble que yo me comparto mis
datos ahorita en este momento los estoy
compartiendo
en las dos escuelas hasta las seis de la
tarde que salgo y yo me estoy
compartiendo con mis datos y mi plano su
venosa
no me gasta más megas porque es gratuita
está patrocinada entonces también por
este lado del costo que a veces decimos
voy a gastar voy a invertir claro que no
esté de tu celular lo comparte la la red
inalámbrica de tus datos al ala a la
laptop y ahí puedes manejar todo y es
muy muy accesible y sin costo
entonces nos ayuda nos favorece en la
diversidad de estudiantes que tenemos
que pueden ver el vídeo las veces que
quieran o unos son muy ágiles y pues
también dicen oh maestra pues con él
como nos explicó ya pudiera desarrollar
todas las actividades a pues en breve no
no dura ni una hora media hora en hacer
las actividades en éste de todo lo que
les asigne la semana entonces yo ya nada
más veo el avance o por alumno por tarea
y es de manera muy sencilla también en
el correo nos manda por semana los los
registros de actividades que presentó
cada grupo entonces todo está muy
estructurado todo está muy esté
organizado entonces no no hay este
problema alguno en el cual no observé y
analice como a nuestros estudiantes
entonces la verdad que si te y muy
agradecida verdad este la oportunidad de
formar parte ahorita de la familia
tiene un excelente muchas gracias a su
familia no sé si alguien en el chat
tenga
tenga dudas vamos a ver
por ahí yo pinto dicen que al mostrar a
mis grupos el avance en el campeonato se
motivaron para pelear los primeros
lugares
eso está padrísimo también dice que ha
agregado las actividades de mentalidad
de crecimiento y les llama la atención
ya que preguntan sobre los temas de los
que se tratan
perfecto
mira compañeros tuyos de varios campos
en manzanillo por ahí
[Música]
guadalupe nuevo león e iztapalapa
tú tú tú tú tú
y de puebla también saludos
e
no sé si tengan por ahí
alguna duda algo que quieran preguntar
la luz emilia aprovechen la la tenemos
aquí ella en invitada súper especial
para que nos comparta su experiencia
[Música]
creo que no no tenemos dudas tú tú tú tú
por ahí a analí herrera
liliana herrera sí si tienes fallas
recuerda iliana que puedes entrar a la
página de soporte
los emilia tus celebras
los logros con tus grupos o sea
compartes con ellos cada vez que
desbloquean un nivel o una copa
sí y es muy motivante eso me lo piden
así como los jueves de rigor yo trabajo
de lunes a jueves
y si se les gusta que yo le dé el clic
el momento del porcentaje que logran el
7 y si se hacen júbilo se hace una
alegría este
tengo algunos vídeos ya es de cada copa
que van avanzando y entre ellos niños
algunos que no han participado de lleno
pues se motiva y veo cada vez más
participaciones en el grupo xiv y mucha
alegría y dicen pues que vamos a ganarle
y pues este sus avances y sus
calificaciones se va a ver reflejado que
es lo importante también le digo que no
lo vayan esté quedándose por reprobación
que tenemos un alto índice de
reprobación luego de deserción en el
nivel primero que es cuando hay más este
cambio de del nivel entonces si veo más
motivación y júbilo este muy entusiastas
aplauden y gritan y y sí sí es muy
motivante los jueves está así de que
tengo que ver el avance y sí sí estamos
en un grupo llegamos en el nivel 11 en
la copa 11 guau está súper bien
y otros estamos en las 5 vamos en la 57
entonces si ellos ven que si es
importante y lo proyectamos en la
pantalla en el cañón y este y hacemos la
grabación en el vídeo
y éste también lo proyecto con un código
que ellos me ayudan porque son pues ya
sabemos nativos digitales con mi celular
con un código y proyectan el vídeo en el
en la pantalla grande para que todos lo
vean y lo disfrutemos si celebramos este
a veces los lunes también si se puede lo
lo comparto y vemos cuánto cuánto han
avanzado y si si si se celebramos y
excelente muchas gracias luz y vida pero
acá nos dicen que usan las actividades
de mentalidad de crecimiento
pues no aparentemente no tenemos hasta
ahorita ninguna
ninguna pregunta
pero bueno aquí tenemos alguna algunos
ejemplos de cómo podemos introducir khan
academy o sacar el mayor provecho de
khan en nuestras clases por ejemplo
podemos tener la práctica alineada la
lección ya sea en que base o enviando
las actividades de tarea digamos y lo
ideal sería hacerlo unas dos o tres
veces por semana pero también podemos
tener repasos en la escuela por ejemplo
o como si fuera de manera remedial
también unas dos o tres veces por mes
durante todo el tiempo de la clase
entonces esto puede ser un refuerzo del
contenido no necesariamente tiene que
ser un modelo de aula invertida siempre
en donde pretendamos que el alumno entra
y revise el contenido y luego venga al
salón y al 'mejor afinemos detalles sino
que el contenido yo lo puedo seguir
trabajando como maestro dentro de la
clase y nada más hago un repaso con
ellos
cada dos o tres veces al mes quizá más o
a lo mejor una vez por semana
dependiendo de la necesidad que ustedes
tengan
también le podemos trabajar porque como
tarea entonces la frecuencia nosotros la
determinamos recuerden que nosotros
podemos asignar actividades pero también
los alumnos son libres digamos de poder
explorar la plataforma a su paso a su
ritmo
y bueno las prácticas individuales que
es lo que es lo que les estoy comentando
cada a cada chico puede explorar el
contenido dependiendo de lo que quieran
aprender de hasta donde quiera llegar o
probarse entonces es un modelo bastante
rico y abierto porque tenemos varias
formas nosotros como docentes de
trabajar en la plataforma
no sé si haya dudas vamos a revisar por
aquí creo que no
si alguien tiene alguna duda de cómo
registrarse al campeonato
les voy a recordar los pasos básicos o
los requerimientos mínimos que son que
podamos tener
por lo menos 10 alumnos registrados en
una clase
y por favor recuerde
recuerden eliminar las clases que tengan
inactivas si tienen todavía por ahí
clases del semestre pasado o del ciclo
anterior pasado eliminen las para que no
nos estorben ahí necesitamos tener por
lo menos 10 alumnos registrados en una
clase y empezar a asignar a actividades
que sean mínimo 3 actividades a la
semana para poder ser parte o ser
considerados como parte del campeonato
saleh
nos decía a lo mejor vale la pena o
valdría la pena entrar
a la página de khan academy por acá
[Música]
no no
para repasar recuerden que una vez que
están dentro del campeonato
aquí luego luego se nos presenta la
opción para revisar su avance entonces
dependiendo de las clases que tengan van
ustedes a poder ver cómo van avanzando y
en qué copa están o en qué nivel están y
los días restantes para completar los
niveles mínimos digamos en donde
debiésemos estar dependiendo de la fecha
no quedan todavía cuatro semanas del
campeonato bueno tres y media casi
porque estamos casi a mitad de semana
entonces no es tarde para empezar para
todos aquellos que no han agregado el
contenido de mentalidad de crecimiento
en cuando ustedes abran su clase que
tienen aquí estas opciones de contenido
tareas actividad de configuración acá en
la configuración
no es cierto perdón perdón acá en
contenido acá en configuración vamos a
eliminar los alumnos a las clases pero
aquí en contenido si nosotros damos clic
acá en la parte de arriba nos da la
opción de editar el curso entonces aquí
es donde podemos agregar el contenido de
mentalidad de crecimiento si es que no
lo tenemos activo recuerden que nos da
más puntos por estas actividades
y acá en configuración bueno podemos
eliminar las clases que tengamos
inactivas las que sean del semestre
pasado o del ciclo pasado las podemos
eliminar aquí si alguien tiene también
por ahí dudas de cómo hacer la
sincronización con google chrome le
pueden hacer acá
si no lo hicieron desde un inicio cuando
crearon la clase no pasa nada la pueden
hacer aquí desde configuración tiene la
opción para sincronizar con google
classroom entonces basta con que ustedes
seleccionen la cuenta
y seleccionen posteriormente las clases
que quieran ligar a la clase que tienen
en khan academy con la que tienen en
google las sales es una de las preguntas
más frecuentes que tenemos
acá en la parte de tareas y actividad
pero en tareas van ustedes a poder ver
lo que se ha estado dejando por alumno
por tarea
en actividad las actividades semanales
yo aquí lo veo de los últimos 7 días
pero pueden ser por más tiempo
vale y podemos regresar acá al menú de
todas nuestras clases
alguien tiene por ahí alguna duda
[Música]
con el epp teziutlán
por ahí al link está
resolviendo la duda para cambiar el
idioma
[Música]
y pues bueno básicamente esto es lo que
lo que cubrimos dentro del campeonato
como como revisar el avance y
configuraciones básicas de las clases
si tienen alguna otra duda háganoslo
saber y si no recuerden que tienen por
ahí el correo electrónico el cual nos
pueden escribir con sus dudas o
comentarios que es o la arroba khan
academy punto o hereje nos dará mucho
gusto saber de ustedes si quieren
compartir nos lo pueden compartir nos
también como celebran los logros con sus
grupos nos daría muchísimo gusto
pueden compartirlo usando el hashtag
campeonato 2018 y sino también
haciéndonos llegar su material a esa
dirección de correo o la canaca de mi
punto o rf
saleh
muchísimas gracias 2 emilia por tu
experiencia nos encanta conocer
profesores tan comprometidos como tú que
buscan la manera de proveer a sus
alumnos con nuevas herramientas y cosas
que les sean atractivas sabemos que no
es fácil lo que lo que ustedes viven
como docentes y que todos los días son
distintos pero te agradecemos muchísimo
que hayas aceptado la invitación y nos
hayas compartido su experiencia el día
de hoy
muchas gracias laura un placer
y que vengan más canciones jajaja a
todos los ciclos escolares ya verás
gracias christina por ahí no sé si
tengas tú algún comentario no pero
muchísimas gracias a ustedes dos y es
muy interesante y inspirador escuchar
como están usando cada caerme
a los presentes no pues muchísimas
gracias por venir muchas gracias a todos
y nos vemos pronto